this is a mini can I'm quite fond of the
mini cans this is like eight ounces so
it's actually larger than the old six
and a half ounce bottles that I grew up
with and I like them because they hold
the fizz you know and they stay
relatively cold longer let me introduce
my my other books really quickly this is
actually my latest book not the code not
the new edition of coke this is called
silly Sadie it's a wonderful children's
book you can find all of these on my
website which my website is my name mark
Pendergrass calm this is Jack in the
bean soup which is an elaborate fart
joke book this is uncommon grounds
history of coffee inside the outbreaks
about disease detectives of the CDC and
there are several AIS X EIS officers in
the audience I know this is mirror
mirror a history of mirrors unbelievably
broad ranging and kind of interesting
Japan's tipping point which is recent I
went looking to see whether they were
really doing a whole lot about renewable
energy after the Fukushima meltdown and
one more let's see victims of memory is
probably my most important book it's
about the repressed memory epidemic of
the late 80s and early 90s when it's
amazing that people can come up with
things that never happened and remember
them very clearly and
it I wanted to I wanted to open this
with a quote from 1985 and I presume if
you are interested in coca-cola that you
know what happened in 1985 they changed
the flavor of coca-cola and the entire
world went insane it's really amazing so
I can't think of another product that
people would have gone so berserk over
and I started the book with a story
about the flavor change because it
strikes me as being so emblematic it was
a history lesson that the public taught
the coca-cola company of what the drink
meant to them and it wasn't so much the
taste of the drink although that was
part of it but but what it meant so I
just gonna read a few of the letters the
company was kind enough to let me have a
file with some of the letters that
people wrote to them in 1985 I am a very
heavy coke drinker I do not drink
coffee tea milk water nothing but coke
I drink coke all day long I always have
a glass or can of coke always I have now
to try and find something to drink that
I can tolerate it will not be new coke
never another letter
changing coke is just like breaking the
American dream like not selling hot dogs
at a ballgame millions of dollars worth
of advertising cannot overcome years of
conditioning or in my case generations
the old coke is in my blood until you
bring the old coke back I'm going to
drink RC
I do not drink alcoholic beverages I
don't smoke and I don't chase other
women my only vice has been coke now you
have taken that pleasure from me my
dearest coke you have betrayed me we
went out just last week as we had so
often and when we kissed I knew our love
affair was over and it goes on and on I
mean it's just amazing so I just wanted
to start out with with that introduction
and the question is how in the world did
that happen how did a drink which is 99%
sugar water come to represent the United
States of America to many people and
come to mean so much and come to have so
much power in the world including
politics and the environment and now
they're being blamed for the obesity
epidemic how did this all happen and so
I'm gonna try to take you for a pretty
quick march through this and I'm sure
I'm not gonna cover everything anybody
wants to hear so please make little
notes about questions you you won't
answer it and I'll try to answer them
Coca Cola was invented in 1886 by this
gentleman this is the only known picture
of him named John Pemberton he was born
in 1831 in rural town in Georgia he
became a pharmacist he was a doctor and
he was a patent medicine maker and he
was convinced he was going to make his
fortune he made things like extract of
Steel India and globe flour cough syrup
and a number of other patent medicines
which you have never heard of so he was
not a very good businessman he would
make money he would give it away he was
also in the Civil War and he was wounded
in it and I believe that that's one of
the reasons why he became a morphine
addict which many many Civil War
veterans did become he also had of
course ready access to it as a
pharmacist although it was perfectly
legal until 1914 anyway
he became very interested he moved to
Atlanta the
city of Atlanta in 1869 determined to
make his fortune and he was sure he had
it in 1884 two years before he invented
coca-cola because he made a drink that
was an imitation of this world-famous
van Mariani you've never heard of a
Mariani but if you had been alive in
1885 you would have known all about it
everybody knew about it
Angelo Mariani was a Corsican who moved
to Paris and who began to make this
Bordeaux wine with an infusion of coca
leaf so it had a good healthy portion of
not only alcohol but cocaine and
everybody thought cocaine was a wonder
drug in the 1880s including Sigmund
Freud and he had endorsements from the
likes of Queen Victoria drank van
Mariani Thomas Edison Emile Zola Sarah
Bernhardt and Pope Leo the 13th loved
his van Mary Annie so naturally with
such a popular drink many people
imitated it including John Pemberton he
created a drink called French wine coca
and it was very clearly of a Mary Annie
ripoff and in in interviews with the
Atlanta Constitution he said as much but
he said mine is better I have made a
superior product and I want to read you
from one of the ads for Van Mary any
because it would give from French wine
coca pardon me give you a good flavor of
Pemberton's style of advertising
Americans are the I'll try a southern
accent I've been living up north so long
this won't be very good he was a
Southern gentleman John Pemberton was
Americans are the most nervous people in
the world all who are suffering from any
nervous complaints we come in to use
that wonderful and delightful remedy
French wine coca infallible and curing
all who are afflicted with any new of
trouble dyspepsia mental and physical
exhaustion all chronic and waste and
diseases gastric irritability
constipation six headache
etc is quickly cured by the coca wine it
is proven the greatest blessing to the
human family nature's God's best gift in
medicine to clergy men lawyers literary
men merchants bankers ladies and all
who's sedentary employment causes
nervous prostration irregularities of
the stomach bowels and kidneys who
require nerve tonic and a pure
delightful died fusible stimulant will
find wine coca invaluable a sure
restorative health and happiness coca is
the most wonderful invigorate of the
sexual organs and will cure Seminole
weakness impotency etc when all other
remedies fail so he went on and on and
on about this drink and he was selling
it like gangbusters when guess what
happened Sam Jones came to town and he
was a Hellfire preacher who convinced
everybody that liquor was evil so
Atlanta was one of the first cities
fulton county voted to go dry there was
a vote in november of 1885 and they to
give people time to adjust to this it
was going to take effect
on July the 1st 1886 so John Pemberton
frantically tried to figure out how he
could modify French wine coca to make
what he called his temperance drink and
that's what coca-cola is ladies and
gentlemen he kept the coca leaf he added
a whole lot of sugar because it was very
bitter with Kola nut which he added also
Kola nut was also a very popular new
drug that contained caffeine and he this
is this is the formula for coca-cola the
new one that I've got in the third
edition this is the reason you should
buy this book and have me autograph that
tonight this is in the handwriting of
Frank Robinson who was Tim Burton's
early partner and then when Pemberton
died two years after inventing it in
1888 Frank Robinson took the drink to
ASIC handler convinced him it was going
to make his fortune and that it would
cure his headaches which it did
and so this is his handwriting if you
look over there where it says coca-cola
flavor then that looked familiar their
handwriting he wrote out the famous
script he named coca-cola which guess
why it's named coca-cola it has coca
leaf and Kola nut that's why the two
principal drug ingredients so it had
cocaine and it had caffeine so but this
nobody's ever found the recipe for
French wine coca and there it is I just
wanted to show you what these were these
are real plants this is what a coca
plant looks like they take these leaves
they make fluid extract of coca with it
they do it still in importing it from
Peru in Maywood New Jersey but they D
cocaine eyes it now they've done that
since 1903 coca-cola has not had any
cocaine well it had a little tiny
smidgen that they got out in the 20s and
this is a color nut and I took this
picture in 2006 when I was doing
research for inside the outbreaks in
these year and so I chewed one of these
I bought one from this beautiful young
woman and chewed it and spit it out
immediately it's incredibly bitter so I
can see why he added so much sugar to it
now they advertised it to children this
is an 1894 ad and they advertised it
this is a 1896 calendar they put it on
things you had to look at a lot they
would give away free matchbooks with
coca-cola logo on it or mirrors or
Japanese fans or calendars and they
early on had very wholesome nice-looking
young women although this one looks a
little bit stoned
and it was a delightful summer and
winter beverage they were trying to sell
it in the winter specific for headache
relief meant so it was at the same time
a medicine and a and a soft drink and it
was served in soda fountains with
carbonated water and around this time
Frank Robinson wrote in a letter I
believe as I recall said women keep
contacting me and saying would you
please stop with the medicinal
advertising just advertise it as a
delicious and refreshing drink because
we don't want to have to feel like we're
sick to drink it and so he began to get
that idea and gradually over the next
few years they began to change the
advertising this is one from 1905 two
years after they took out the cocaine
and they're still advertising it with
little children as you know men women
and children all healthy and happy and
all drinking coca-cola let me just
mention why they took out the cocaine
cocaine had been a wonder drug in the
1880s but gradually it became clear that
it was an addictive drug that was a real
problem but the reason they really took
it out was that coca-cola was a very
southern drink and there were rumors
that black people were drinking too much
coca-cola getting high on the cocaine
raping white women murdering their
bosses so and this this was in
newspapers that I found at the time I'm
quite convinced that's one of the
reasons one of the main reasons that
they were forced from racism that they
removed the cocaine from coca-cola this
is another one showing a kind of you
know it says Rx it's a prescription for
students and brain workers it's supposed
to make you smarter as the drink was
quite controversial even after they took
the cocaine out
the company decided to try to make it a
patriotic beverage so here you see Uncle
Sam pulling a coke out of the White
House soda fountain it didn't do them
any good though because this man whose
name is Harvey Wiley hated Coca Cola and
he was kind of like the Ralph Nader of
his day very powerful very popular he
was the one who got the Pure Food and
Drug Act passed in 1906 and he was the
first head of the FDA or what came to be
known as the FDA and he got the company
he got the US government to sue Coca
Cola in 1911 which almost put them out
of business and one of his big
complaints was that caffeine was an
added deleterious ingredient that they
were trying to promote to children and
coke barely survived this lawsuit and if
you want I hope you'll read the whole
chapter about it I'm not going to go
into detail here but one of the things
that came out of that was that they
agreed never to show children under the
age of 12 drinking Coca Cola in an ad
again and they as far as I know never
have but here is Harvey Wiley in a 1912
Good Housekeeping article warning the
public against the gremlins of
nervousness habit and in digestion in
coca-cola that's what a coke glass
looked like now asic handler he always
wanted to have a very wholesome women
and no overt sexual appeals more just
kind of sexual appeals this was his
bottle ER in Chicago who showed this
prostitute who was very happy and tired
and says satisfied underneath
and and you can see the empty coke
bottles so Candler didn't like that but
he took the idea and made that ad from
it instead coke early on realized that
they should have sports celebrities
advertising their drink Robert Woodruff
who took over the company in 1923 was
very good friends with Ty Cobb and
convinced him to buy coke stock in 1919
when it went public and it was the basis
of Cobbs fortune as it should have been
the basis of my fortune and my father's
fortune who was sitting in the front row
here because my father's father
JB Pendergrass was a pharmacist in
Little Five Points and bought coca-cola
stock in 1919 but sold it a few years
later for what he thought was a good
profit in order to build a house
[Music]
unfortunate this is an ad from 1922
showing the relatively new at that time
hobble skirt bottle or the contour
bottle what happened was coke had a
contest in 1915
to select a bottle that people would
recognize a blind man would recognize in
the dark or you know that anybody would
know was Coca Cola and the reason they
did this was not for advertising but for
legal purposes they wanted to sue people
who were imitating them and they wanted
not to be able to be imitated and it's a
so that's how this classic bottle was
created by the way the bottling began in
1899 in a big way when these two
Chattanooga lawyers went to ASIC handler
and said we want to bottle it and he
said well I don't want it bottles it's
not a good product the top keeps blowing
off it blow the bottles blow up but I
tell you what I'll give you guys the
rights to bottle it across the United
States but you have to use my syrup and
so he that created this incredible
franchised bottling system and it also
created tension between the Bob lers and
the company forevermore
and numerous lawsuits came out of that
and you'll have to read the book to find
out what they were so during the
Depression era Robert Woodruff worked
with an ad man named Archie Lee and
between them they came up with some of
the best and most classic coca-cola
advertising ever Robert Woodruff said no
more defensive ads we're not going to
say oh it's not bad for you and we're
not going to worry about the fact that
the government sued us and that the army
banned it from army bases in 1907 we're
just going to say it's a wholesome
product and it's a wonderful kind of
affordable luxury and during the
Depression this was a great thing you
know for only five cents you could give
yourself a little pause that refreshes
and that was this wonderful ad line that
Archie Lee came up with so the pause
that refreshes became synonymous with
coca-cola and here are these wholesome
lovely beauties that if you like
coca-cola they will like you too
obviously so that would be good here is
a serving tray again stuff that you look
at or that you use all the time they
were very good at doing this this is a
Norman Rockwell a picture of a wholesome
freckle-faced boy drinking coke he looks
awful close to being under 12 but I
don't think he is but this was during a
time when when the United States was
urbanizing quickly and even then Coke
was harkening back to as kind of a
mythical past were very good at doing
that still very good at doing that now
they couldn't show children drinking it
but they sure did want to get children
to drink their drink from an early age
and to become loyal to it and literally
addicted to it so who better to
represent their drink than Santa Claus
this ad Haddon Sundblom a wonderful
artist I prefer him to Norman Rockwell
painted the Santa Claus is starting in
1931 and they're still going on as you
know and
it really defined the way we think of
Santa Claus up until then some of them
were fat and jolly and dressed in red
but some were gone and tall and wore
green forever more
Santa would look like this and would
prefer coca-cola and when I was growing
up we had a cute little coca-cola Santa
Claus by the fireplace remember that
with a little tiny coca-cola
and mom and dad would just stand up just
for a moment I my dad made part of its
living by making display racks for
coca-cola and he helped me with
introducing me to many people and I was
first writing the first edition of the
book now
during world war ii was really this is
just beyond comprehension
they exempted coca you know when when
Pearl Harbor happened Robert Woodruff
said we will provide a coca-cola for our
fighting men no matter where they are in
the world for only a nickel no matter
how much it costs us and it was a great
patriotic gesture but it was also a
brilliant marketing move as a result
coca-cola was deemed an essential morale
booster for the troops they sent
coca-cola men overseas dressed in army
uniforms with tio on their shoulders
stood for technical observer a technical
observer was a civilian who was
essential to the war effort most of them
did things like fixing airplanes these
guys set up coca-cola 64 coca-cola
bottling plants behind the lines to give
to the Troops and it really was a morale
booster again I have all these letters I
won't read you now but they're in the
book of what it meant to people to get a
coca-cola in the middle of warfare in
the trenches well what this did was to
set them up after the war with you know
everybody knew coke was the GI strength
Pepsi was screaming bloody murder all
this time
and they didn't get the same treatment I
thought this was a funny ad by a cartoon
by Bill Malden congratulations you're
the 100th soldier who has posed with
that bottle of coca-cola you can drink
it now at the same time that coca-cola
was the big patriotic drink which you
know it's amazing it had become this big
patriotic drink after the US government
had sued them not that long ago 30 years
or so before it was very popular inside
Nazi Germany this is a 1937 cover of
coca-cola no friction' coca-cola news
and in 1938 I found the that Max kite
who was the head of coca-cola in Germany
who had a little mustache like Hitler
was leading chance of Sieg Heil to the
Fuhrer while there was a coca-cola logo
right next to a huge swastika it was
really shocking now max kite was not a
Nazi himself but he had to go along to
get along and his you know I called that
chapter Coca Cola uber alles because for
him for him it was Coca Cola over
everything and he actually almost was
sent to a concentration camp himself
because he refused to nationalize it but
he came up during the war with Fanta a
drink called Fanta and it wasn't a fruit
drink it was sort of leftovers of
leftovers but that's what the company
used later on when they decided to go
into fruit drinks they used that name so
after the war coca-cola was launched for
international expansion this is a cover
from Time magazine from 1950 says world
and friend love that piaster that lira
and that tiki and that American Way of
life it so Coke had become a symbol of
the American Way of life for good and
for bad
so the Communists spread all these
rumors that coca-cola turns your hair
white overnight that it made you
impotent that it was awful for you
and nonetheless coke persevered so it
was almost banned in France the
winemakers didn't when the mineral water
makers did not want it so I have a whole
chapter in the book called cocoa
colonization and the Communists which I
found interesting now coke was very good
at doing advertising on the radio and
when television came along they jumped
on board too they sponsored Ozzie and
Harriet the perfect American family to
drink Coca Cola with little Ricky doing
so also now at the same time they Robert
Woodruff did not like change so he
didn't want to change from the one drink
one size one price it was a six and a
half ounce hobble skirt bottle for a
nickel and that's all there was
well Coke Pepsi Pepsi had come along
during the Depression and put Pepsi and
twelve ounce old beer bottles and they
had a little jingle that said you know
Pepsi Cola hits the spot twelve full
ounces that's a lot twice as much for a
nickel too Pepsi Cola is the drink for
you
so Pepsi got an image of being a low
quality drink for cheap people but it
sold a lot of pepsi and coke coke
refused to match them and just sort of
was above them all four years nobody at
coca-cola would say the word Pepsi it
was the P word you'd say the imitator or
the competitor you wouldn't even name
them well finally they broke down and
they match the mounts around and they
came out with king sized coke and then
finally they came out with sprite and
with Fanta and tab the their first
hideous diet drink although I don't want
to offend people many people love tab
everybody likes something and then they
become it used to it even if it does
taste like kerosene
and so coca-cola had never addressed a
huge market the african-american market
was very big for coca-cola but they only
showed black people in ads as domestic
servants and throughout the 20s and 30s
and here in the 1950s they showed Sugar
Ray Robinson but this ad was in Ebony or
another publication for blacks so they
had sort of separate but unequal ads and
it wasn't until the 1960s when they were
basically forced by the civil rights
movement to not only show blacks in
their ads and this is a real thing at
but also to there's an incredible story
in the book of Charlie bottoms and
Charlie Boone the first black sales rep
that Coke had and and what they went
through together as a team in the 1960s
with death threats and people dumping
food in their laps when they tried to
eat together in restaurants etc now to
Coca Cola's credit Robert Woodruff was
the one who said to Atlanta businessmen
when Martin Luther King won the Nobel
Peace Prize in 1964 you will go to the
dinner in honor of Martin Luther King
and when he was killed in 1968 coca-cola
helped to pay for the funeral and to
make sure that Atlanta didn't blow up
the way the rest of the country was but
it's been an interesting thing
you know there was a racial
discrimination lawsuit not long ago at
all that coca-cola finally settled but
there have been racial issues right
along now this real thin campaign I
think was brilliant they wanted to
appeal to hippies and they wanted to
appeal to the old generation at the same
time and the hippies were looking for
authentic things you know they wanted to
do their thing and to be real in terms
of authentic and so this ad managed to
appeal to them as well as this is the
authentic thing meaning it's also not
Pepsi etc and then in 1971 as part of
the real thing campaign they did this
this iconic commercial which we all know
so well in which these they lip syncs to
the group the new seekers who actually
sang the song but it's a very moving ad
and it shows everybody holding coca-cola
as if it were a talisman of peace that
the world would only it would be at
peace if everybody would drink coca-cola
and I you know it seems absurd but I
kind of think that's true in a way at
the end of the book I talked about the
power of capitalism - you know coca-cola
doesn't want to see people at war you
can't sell very much coca-cola if if
people are killing each other and so in
many ways they they have tried to keep
the world at peace they were very much
involved with the transition to power
from white apartheid South Africa and
Nelson Mandela in a very good way anyway
we all know that commercial let me see
oh this is gonna be on television I have
to sing I'd like to teach that come on
the world to sing
in perfect harmony thank you so there
was this mean there was this Mean Joe
green commercial from 1979 that is also
absolutely wonderful somebody said that
he looked like a fellow when he was he
turned around and said hey kid and
through his sweaty Jersey to him after
the kid said mr. green mr. green I think
you're the best ever but I found out in
my research that they made him do 18
takes and that he threw up after the six
and and then they used the first take
the poor guy so here is 1985 which I've
already talked about Roberto Gazeta was
a brilliant CEO who came to Coke from
Cuba where because of Castro and he had
worked for coca-cola in Cuba before
Castro nationalized the business and he
came in and he said there are no sacred
formulas there are no sacred cows and
nobody ever considered that he really
meant it but coke had been losing market
share to Pepsi for 20 years and they'd
had great ads and what was the matter
and they they had this annoying Pepsi
challenge and they decided well we're
gonna change it and make it taste better
than Pepsi and they did about 51% of
people preferred the taste of new coke
to Pepsi the other 49% was almost burned
down the
so for three months there were these
huge protests and they finally brought
back coke classic and and then it
reminded people of what coke meant to
them and the same drink that had been
losing market share has been gaining
market share basically ever since so
much so that many people think that this
was a hoax that coke intended to do this
let me tell you they did not intend to
do it I'm going to jump to because I
need to finish things this is an ad from
the killer coke campaign that was
launched in 2003 a guy named Ray Rodgers
who is a longtime union activist started
this now the fact is that there were
union members in coca-cola Bottling
class in Colombia who were murdered in
the 1990s and the question is did the
coca-cola bottler was was the coca-cola
bottler in collusion with the
paramilitary groups who committed these
murders I think it's entirely possible
that they were I it's difficult to prove
this one way or the other I very much
doubt that anyone in Atlanta had
anything to do with it on the other hand
the company has always you know said
well those are the bottlers that's not
us but the fact is the bubblers can't do
business unless you sell them those
concentrates or the syrup or whatever
you want to call it so this was a huge
campaign which is still going on they
tried to do a lawsuit which got thrown
out of court eventually but this is the
kind of thing that coca-cola absolutely
hates for very good reason
but it also has has made them begin to
pay attention to a lot of human rights
allegations around the world which i
think is it's a good thing that they
to pay more attention to them but let me
say I think that coca-cola is
essentially a pretty good company in
many many ways every major corporation
does awful things coca-cola is held
accountable in a way that many companies
aren't because it is this image drink
you know it's the perfect drink for
people to protest because you can
protest them so my book is not an anti
coca-cola book it's not a pro coca-cola
book it is a very well researched book
that offers you the facts as I came to
know them on both sides of the issue
for instance they were accused in India
quite recently of depleting the water
table now India has terrible water
problems but 98% of those problems come
from the very poor way that they
irrigate and that they do agriculture
coca-cola some of their bottling plants
they shouldn't have put them where they
put them in areas with bad drought and
they did contribute to also depleting
the water table but it's a little hard
to blame them entirely for this and they
have now begun to replenish the water
with rainwater harvesting under Neville
Israel who came in in 2004 as the CEO
they began to focus on water issues
around the world for instance when I
went to Kenya as part of the research
for inside the outbreaks the CDC's doing
something called the safe water system
which teaches people to put dilute
bleach in containers and then they have
a narrow top so you can't stick your
hand in to dip anything out Andry
pollute it well lo and behold there was
coke paying for this program in
elementary schools so that was that was
very heartening to me so I do take these
allegations seriously but in this
particular case I I think that they
perceived more blame than they deserve
coca-cola has been having a have you
used these free style machines anybody
you know they're kind of cool aren't
they you can go and you can choose
different things this is part of
coca-cola trying to be more interactive
with their advertising and with their
marketing they want to involve consumers
they had they had a hidden camera when
they were testing this someplace in
Atlanta and they had a they caught a
woman who kissed the side of the machine
that was quite funny but you can sort of
mix and match here in a modern version
of what they used to call the suicide at
the soda fountain and this is Monsieur
Kent who is the by the way Neville is
del was from is from Ireland originally
grew up a lot of in large measure in
South Africa was an anti-apartheid
activist when he was a student and he
brought back Muhtar Kent to be his sort
of second-in-command and then when he
retired in 2008 as the CEO
Muhtar Kent took over he is a Turkish
American his father was the ambassador
to the United States and to many other
countries as Kent was growing up his
father was one of the people who saved
Jews during the Holocaust from being
sent to the gas chambers so this is Kent
who is very much a coca-cola man
delivering the first case of coca-cola
and Myanmar Burma leaving only last year
leaving only Cuba and North Korea as
places where you cannot legally buy coke
of course you can buy coke there on the
black market anyway so I mean coca-cola
is the world's most widely distributed
single product it is probably the second
best known word on earth after the word
okay I don't know if that's still true
or not
it it has huge amounts of money flowing
in it has a really good profit margin it
also has given huge amounts of money to
good causes particularly here in the
city of Atlanta but they also have given
a lot of money to the World Wildlife
Fund to AIDS prevention and treatment in
Africa because they are the largest
single private employer in Africa and a
number of other things that you probably
don't know about now
they have been blamed for the obesity
epidemic and they have reacted this year
by coming out with ads saying we're part
of the solution not the problem and some
of that rings quite hollow to me for
instance they say look we've reduced how
much sugary soft drinks and calories we
give to children in schools well that's
because they were basically forced out
of schools in 2006 so now they're
bragging about it but they do offer
about a quarter of their products now
our low-calorie or no calorie and again
this is good business because sugary
soft drinks peaked in 1988 in terms of
per capita consumption in the United
States and they've been dwindling down
they came out recently with Coke Zero
which is aimed primarily at men who
don't like to say a drink is a diet
drink and it uses the real coca-cola
formula whereas Diet Coke doesn't I
think at some point in the future the
combined sales of Diet Coke and Coke
Zero will surpass a regular coca-cola so
but and and you know a 12 ounce can of
coca-cola has nine teaspoons of sugar in
it or well high fructose corn syrup in
this country the equivalent of sugar
that's a lot of sugar so they should be
held accountable not for the entire
obesity epidemic but for trying to
encourage people to drink a huge amount
of the sugar Laden
the thing that I wish they would do and
I'm very glad that they're supporting
exercise programs and that they're I'm
glad that they're paying attention to
this issue I wish they would not spend
millions of dollars through the American
Beverage Association to fight taxes on
soda I think that they should embrace
that because you know until they put
high taxes on cigarettes you know you
can preach to people till you're blue in
the face but preaching doesn't make
people change their behavior money makes
people change their behavior so I and
this is a controversial thing to say
even among nutritionists but I think
that we should have higher taxes on
sugary beverages because it will reduce
the consumption but they're not likely
to agree with me this is from the
company website from January of this
year announcing their efforts and to
beat one of the most serious complex
issues of this generation obesity and I
applaud them for doing that and and
they're right they now offer something
like 3500 drinks around the world this
is a company that offered one drink in
one size till 1955 and they've done that
in large measure by buying a lot of
other companies like they spent four
billion dollars to 4 point 1 billion
dollars to buy glass--oh which makes a
vitamin water a few years ago they're
not that good at being nimble in
creating new drinks but they have a
section of people who just look at new
drinks and try to find the next winner
so they can buy it the future for
coca-cola and for other soft drink
companies is China where they have
formed business partnerships with the
Chinese government and the Chinese
government has committed many human
rights abuses including right before the
2008 Olympics in Beijing which coca-cola
paid for the
Olympic torch run they cracked down hard
on Tibet and that was a huge issue just
a few years ago so there's a lot of
politics involved oh I wanted to mention
one thing about politics coca-cola has
been involved with getting various
presidents elected beginning most
notably with Eisenhower who was a great
buddy of Robert Woodruff and then when
Jimmy Carter was running for president
coca-cola was very helpful to him and
Carter when he was the governor called
coca-cola his State Department because
when he went to a foreign country he
could ask the coca-cola people for the
lowdown on the politics and everything
else and they would know it better than
anybody else I thought I would mention
that since I'm here at the Carter Center
and with that I think I will turn this
off and thank you very much for your
attention this long
we have time for about 10 or 15 minutes
worth of questions please raise your
hand and wait for the microphone and
then ask your question you'd mentioned
that Coke Zero had the original coke
flavoring as opposed to Diet Coke which
does not can you address why Diet Coke
has more caffeine than coke zero why it
has more caffeine than cousin zero look
again I did not know that
Diet Coke has 46 milligrams per 12 ounce
can Coke Zero has 34 as does the drink
you're drinking mm-hmm
I have no idea why why do you think that
would be I think skinny folks jittery
[Laughter]
that that could well be the case
[Music]
see I don't know everything about Coca
Cola my question is I just two weeks ago
I toured the corporate headquarters of
Coca Cola so it's weird saying their
version of what Coca Cola is and more of
an unbiased version and I kinda had a
couple comments because they gave it
gave me some of the facts and maybe you
knew it maybe you know or maybe you
don't know is on that Times article when
it had the world with Coca Cola they
originally wanted Robert Woodruff to be
on the cover but he didn't want to be so
that's why they put the symbol and then
the other one is for the freestyle
machines and like all of the modern
machines you can't actually buy them but
it's more of renting them from coca-cola
so that's one also another thing so like
what they're high-tech technology right
right you have to rent their they don't
even call them vending machines they
call them soda fountains you're
absolutely right that Robert Woodruff
refused you know Robert Wood was known
as mr. anonymous he didn't really like
attention
he didn't want to be on the cover of
time and he didn't want people Dunning
him for money either so you know when
Ralph McGill wrote an article called The
Millionaire and nobody knows
Woodruff wasn't that happy about it but
let me just clarify something you did
not take a tour of the corporate
headquarters you took a tour of the
world of coca-cola museum is that right
oh oh you really did get to go to the
corporate headquarters at North Avenue
no I'm impressed
the world of coca-cola museum as you
know also every time I go there I ask
the guide whether coca-cola ever had
cocaine in it and they always tell me no
no it hasn't had any and so long you
know I don't see why they can't do that
but yeah that sounds like a fascinating
tour you had just very recently I
learned I read that the person who
actually combined the syrup with the
carbon dioxide was then a guy named
inable connected to the Stone Mountain
Venables and I confirmed that with a
member of the family that's the first
time I'd ever heard that is have you
heard that
Willis Venable was the one who ran the
soda fountain at Jacobs pharmacy in 1886
so he would be the first person who
mixed it together with carbonated water
that's absolutely true there is a myth
that Coca Cola was accidentally mixed
with carbonated water but it was
intended to be mixed with it from right
along and that's what Venable did and
you know carbonated drinks came out of
this tradition of thinking that water is
at spas naturally carbonated waters were
good for you and then Joseph Priestley
in the late 1700s figured out how to
artificially carbonate things and that
that's why a lot of the soda fountains
were in pharmacies was because it was
supposed to be good for you
I've traveled around internationally a
lot and I found that every country I've
been to the coke tastes a little bit
different
does it have to do the water or do they
change the formula a little bit
depending on the audience a Coca Cola is
very proud of the fact that they have a
uniform product anywhere in the world
and they would dispute what you just
said however I think that the main
difference is cane sugar they they put
real sugar in Coca Cola in many
countries in the world they don't do
that in the United States because we
have a protective tariff so high
fructose corn syrup is cheaper and so
there's a whole kind of gourmet core
Coca Cola imported from Mexico that
people will pay a lot of money for now
but it's possible that there are other
differences I'm not aware of them you
know it's a political question I think
Coca Cola is a pretty good company in
the United States and it's that way
because many of us made it become a
better company because at a time when
you know you couldn't buy Bartling
companies you're an African American but
I've been working with Coca Cola the
last ten years in Brazil where they've
made that largest investment in the
world and as you may know coca-cola in
Brazil Brazil is about 50 50 50 African
and 50 percent Caucasian but Africans in
Brazil are not afforded opportunities to
advance in coca-cola and we've been
trying to tell them the fallacy of that
and I hope it don't blow up on with a
World Cup and the Olympics heading to
Brazil as we speak
and this is this is Joe Beasley I
believe yeah that's great
and you've been act an activist trying
to get Coca Cola to behave itself in
terms of racial issues for quite some
time is that correct all over the world
and I think unless coca-cola changes its
Africa
market they're going to have tremendous
problems in a ver because most of the
ownership
and that coca growth product in Africa
but the ownership of coca-cola Africa is
outside of Africa and I believe in that
information age that's going to kind of
blow up on them we want to help them we
like coca-cola we want to help them be a
better company and I hope they'll listen
what do you think of it and they make a
big deal out of the fact that in Africa
particularly they have these spouses the
little drink stands that sell a few
things besides coca-cola and that they
really do help many people to make a
living well that that's true but
nonetheless the big bucks of being made
by the shareholders mm-hmm and the
shareholders are not the applicants and
we've cautioned coke about that to
restructure themselves and so I hope
they will heed we're still in a helping
mode we don't want to get in a mode
where we start litigating again like in
Brazil which i think is a distinct
possibility that I've talked to some
same lawyers that we we sued coke for
hundred ninety million dollar judgment
as you recall in nineteen this is a
racial discrimination lawsuit in the
United States yes yes I recall that I
wrote about that I do not know about
Brazil so let me talk to you after this
event please all right thank you
so I found your your presentation
fascinating I'm actually a coca-cola
employee I'll be having my 30th
anniversary as a coke employee next
month and so two very small corrections
to a couple things that you said first
of all actually agree with you about
coke always wanting to have kind of an
own product and a something that when
you when you get a coke anywhere in the
world you know what you're going to get
but we do actually modify it somewhat
for local tastes so coke in Mexico will
be a little bit sweeter then somewhere
else that you go in the world that also
uses sugar same sweetener the local
taste preference is a little bit
different correct it's one toid second
factoid is that you can get coca-cola in
Cuba I've been to Cuba twice and and
certainly have been able to purchase it
without problem the difference is that
it is sold by our Mexican independent
bottle or coca-cola fencer and so you
can't have direct you know there's no
direct relationship with any kind of
commerce that goes on in Cuba but
certainly Mexico has very good relations
with Cuba and you don't have to buy it
on the black market
no it's available in restaurants pretty
much not necessarily where only locals
go it's quite expensive in with respect
to the local economy but for a tourists
that are there it's it's very easy to
find I wonder if that's true in North
Korea not
[Laughter]
well thank you I'm relieved that those
are the only two things I had that you
noticed that I got wrong thank you I
understand that that there are people
that have seen the original formula of
coca-cola I mean not the original but
the present formula for coca-cola and
one on being rabbi tobias Geffen of
Atlanta so that he passed on judgment
whether coca-cola was kosher for
Passover that has been a legend here in
Atlanta and I do know that coca-cola
sells Coke for Passover that that
Orthodox Jews do consume I mean it has I
didn't know was what let me let me
interrupt you're saying rabbi Geffen was
the the rabbi who did verify that Coke
was kosher in the 1930s it was very
important to coke that he do so they did
not give him the formula they gave him
the ingredients they didn't it's a
important distinction I looked through
his papers very carefully and I'm pretty
sure about this they did change the
formula because of him they had glycerin
made from animal fat and they they
changed that and they changed something
else too
let me just mention one of the things
really interesting you know I said
coca-cola was doing very well inside
Nazi Germany during the 1930s a German
competitor who put out something called
Africa law came over to the United
States and went on a tour of a coca-cola
bottling plant in New York and he
swooped up some bottle caps that had the
kosher sign on them brought them back to
Germany and made huge stink about how
coca-cola was this Jewish drink inside
Germany I wanted to ask you also I'm a
shareholder in coca-cola and since I
retired I go to the annual meeting since
they hold them in Atlanta and do you
comment in your book about the old boy
network amongst the directors where it's
self-perpetuating I mean now they're
beginning to get some
Neuer blood but it's still an old boy
network yeah I wonder if you comment on
that
well I commented on that there they have
rather elderly Board of Directors and
that there's been a lot of comment about
that but that's about as far as I went I
went to the annual meeting last year I
didn't go to the one this year it was
interesting the one last year the the
killer cup people have had this
coordinated thing of point of order you
lie point of order you like did they do
that this year
[Laughter]
what's a cokes relationship with Emory
and Georgia Tech universities well I
don't know as much about Georgia Tech
but I do know that you know stretching
back to ASA Candler who gave a million
dollars to Emory at Oxford to help them
move to Atlanta and then Robert Woodruff
gave a huge amount millions and millions
to Emory so that you know Emory has
always been known as coca-cola
University I don't know as much about
Georgia Tech you could probably tell me
I know that the architect Robert Smith
who did the original coke brick
coca-cola bottling company buildings
also did the original Georgia Tech
campus well that would make sense
because they're all right near each
other yeah thank you
two more questions of all I fortunately
if anyone cares I find that you can get
coca-cola with sugar at Kroger in their
ethnic and it's only a dollar a bottle
otherwise was there any thought of
keeping the New Coke and the classic
coke or once they brought the classic
back the new demand for new coke which
was supposed to replicate Pepsi just
died out well first let me say they did
keep both of them for quite some time
Roberta cos Wetty absolutely refused to
admit that new coke was a failure or the
he kept he drank new coke himself and he
said this is the real Coca Cola and
we've just brought back coke classic for
the few misguided people who prefer it
but and in fact it it did not do well I
thought what you were going to ask which
is an interesting question is did they
consider keeping the old coke and coming
out with new coke in the first place and
they did consider that but they quickly
rejected it because that would have
split their market it would have had two
Coca Cola's which was inconceivable to
them and it was quite possible that
Pepsi would have surpassed you know one
of the other of them to be the best
selling soft drink in the country now by
the way Pepsi is the third best selling
soft drink in the country coca-cola
nut is number one and Diet Coke is
number two
[Music]
the last question here yes I know that
Santa has quit smoking cigarettes in the
ads at least I was wondering if there's
any progress on Santa reducing his coke
intake and lose some weight that's a
brilliant idea I think wouldn't that
make a great ad campaign
Santa drinking a Coke Zero and slimming
down I think I think you're on to
something first
perhaps you will take honey
yeah thank you very much I believe that
the better I think you agree it's been a
fascinating evening if you have not
already got a copy of for god country
and coca-cola encourage you to get one
Mark's going to be signing them in the
lobby you please join us there let's get
mark
[Applause]
so I'll see you out there then thank you